buonasera a tutti come avete sentito vi
parlerò della valanga delle tecnologie
quantistiche e per quel che riguarda
probabilmente nel prossimo quarto d'ora
vi sentirete più o meno così perché vi
parlerò del mondo della meccanica
quantistica di come quello che noi
stiamo facendo nei nostri laboratori per
capire l'universo per capire il mondo
delle particelle il mondo delle galassie
il mondo dei buchi neri ci porta anche
attraverso alcuni paradossi e il gatto
di schrodinger che si trova nel titolo
della mia presentazione appunto questo
gatto ha chiuso in una scatola di cui vi
racconterò qualcosa a breve un gatto che
uno zombie gato sia morto che vivo nella
stessa nello stesso tempo di come queste
ricerche qui sul sulle quali sto
lavorando su cui si litiga nella
comunità scientifica soprattutto quella
dei fisici quantistici ci porta verso
tecnologie inimmaginabili fantastiche e
meravigliose di cui io vi darò un unico
esempio il computer quantistico non è
l'unico ma è quello più vicino anche le
tecnologie di oggi voi sapete che
abbiamo passato da qualche decina d'anni
la prima rivoluzione quantistica c'è
qualcuno che ancora non ha capito che
siamo nel procinto di avviarci verso la
seconda rivoluzione quantistica anche la
prima si basa sulla meccanica
quantistica
se non altro perché il transistor
funziona avendo alla base le leggi della
meccanica quantistica attraverso il
silicio eccetera eccetera e l'invenzione
del transistor nonché insieme la
capacità di miniaturizzare quello che
noi stiamo utilizzando quindi la
microelettronica la capacità di
integrare un numero sempre più grande di
transistor su unità di superficie ci ha
permesso di avere delle cose che
purtroppo non ci stupiscono più appunto
cose come i computer meravigliosi cose
come il mio telefonino
che posso usare in tempo reale per farli
a tutti
sorridete una foto che in teoria
potrebbe arrivare all'altro capo del
mondo instantaneamente non è fantastico
tutto ciò eppure questo è niente
rispetto a quello che potrebbe accadere
nel futuro proprio attraverso il lavoro
della fisica quantistica che ci permette
di arrivare a tecnologie che oggi
nemmeno immaginiamo
questa è la legge di moore che vedete
alle mie spalle e ci dà la misura del
progresso la misura dell'integrazione
della capacità di calcolo sempre più
grande che sperimentiamo nelle
tecnologie attuali ma fin dove possiamo
integrare sempre più piccolo sempre più
piccolo esistono sempre più piccolo fin
dove a un certo punto si arriverà la
scala atomica
quindi un circuito più piccolo di un
altro modo impossibile farlo
e allora che si fa quindi si arriva la
fisica atomica la scala atomica ci
imbattiamo nel limite della meccanica
quantistica
oddio che si fa in questo caso non
sfruttiamo e quello che si intende fare
attraverso la valanga delle tecnologie
quantistiche cos'è la quantistica per la
meccanica quantistica è una parola che
affascina tanti pochi sanno di cosa si
tratta
parzialmente anche noi fisici talvolta
non sappiamo bene di cosa si tratta e vi
farò viaro l'esempio appunto di questo
famoso gatto di schrodinger sul quale
stiamo litigando tutt'oggi la meccanica
quantistica e dietro dinamite la
conferenza più famosa della storia della
fisica
la conferenza di solvay del 1927
riconoscete personaggi come einstein
madame curie forse dinger chi di voi è
più magari avvezzo a riconoscere i
personaggi della fisica moderna
la fisica quantistica e la teoria che
vale nel mondo del microscopico nel
mondo degli atomi per intenderci quelli
in cui intorno ad un nucleo di carica
positiva volteggiano come dei ballerini
dovetti degli elettroni ebbene questo
mondo delle particelle descritto dal
punto di vista matematico da un
equazione che si chiama appunto
l'equazione di schrodinger questa parola
così astrusa in cui il sistema viene
descritto attraverso una soluzione di
un'equazione lasciate stare non voglio
entrare nei dettagli
voglio solo dirvi che la soluzione
talvolta non è una sola ma possono
coesistere più soluzioni
cioè più funzioni di stato funzioni
d'onda dunque la soluzione per un
sistema quantistico
e quello che si dice in una
sovrapposizione di stati in quanto la
soluzione globale la somma la
sovrapposizione di tutto quello che può
capitare quindi il sistema quantistico
si trova simultaneamente in tutti gli
stati in cui potrebbe trovarsi è da qui
che nasce hai dato da qui che nasce
questo paradossale dato racchiuso in una
scatola con un sistema quantistico il
sistema quantistico in questo caso una
sorgente radioattiva una sorgente che
funziona con le leggi della meccanica
quantistica che ci dicono che la
sorgente può decadere a una certa
probabilità di decadere in un certo
intervallo di tempo e allora laddove la
sorgente decade fa scattare un perverso
meccanismo che ammazza il dato però la
sorgente ha una probabilità limitata
mettiamo 50 per cento di disintegrarsi
in dieci minuti la zona non era
chiudiamo in una scatola il nostro gatto
con questa sorgente che è il sistema
quantistico passati dieci minuti quello
che sappiamo è che la sorgente a 50 per
cento probabilità di disintegrarsi e
dunque ammazzare il gatto trascorsi
dieci minuti
come si trova il gatto sia morto che
vivo lo zombie gato ed è questo e il
gatto di schrodinger in una perfetta
sovrapposizione di strati gatto morto e
gatto vivo
e ha proposto di questo vivido la
definizione della meccanica quantistica
tra le quale fatta dal suo padre
fondatore niels bohr cosa si può dire di
più
la meccanica quantistica è un grande
paradosso non per questo non funziona
anzi
ritorniamo al nostro computer
quantistico e allora se arriviamo al
limite microscopico laddove non possiamo
fare transistor più piccoli dell'atomo
che si fa arriva 1982 due signori uno
forse vi è noto richard feynman il
grande feinmann insieme a david dobkin
hanno proposto ma perché non sfruttiamo
proprio queste particolari proprietà
anzi la principessa della meccanica
quantistica il principio di
sovrapposizione per fare qualcosa di
completamente nuovo e innovativo per
capire cos'è innovativo in un computer
nella tecnologia quantistica partiamo
dai computer attuali dai circuiti
attuali che funzionano con la corrente
elettrica
la corrente elettrica passa o non passa
abbiamo 10 oppure un 1 codice binario
tutto quello che noi inseriamo in un
computer attuale si trasforma in
corrente che passa oppure non passa
questo si chiama bit e possiamo avere
zero oppure bit 1 corrente passa
perfetto questo è un sistema classico
però un sistema quantistico come un
computer quantistico sfrutta la
sovrapposizione di stati non c'è più una
corrente che ho passa oppure non passa
bensì si trova un sistema che si trova
nel appunto la sovrapposizione di stati
che è quella che a 0 e 1 simultaneamente
più o meno tipo 44 gatti in fila per sei
col resto di due e o meno così quindi
dal gatto di schroedinger a una
sovrapposizione quantistica 0 e 1
simultaneamente una sinfonia quantistica
meraviglio
immaginatevi che potenza a questo
computer una potenza incredibile che
magari fra dieci vent'anni ci farà
sembrare i nostri computer attuali dei
tricicli poveri tre cd per da giocare
per i bambini mentre la tecnologia
futura ci sembrerà qualcosa di
completamente diverso che sta nascendo
ora perfetto ma allora esistono computer
quantistici
se siamo così bravi li sappiamo fare
sì li sappiamo fare nel senso che quelli
sono questi sistemi in sovrapposizione
di stati dove si trovano questi mini
gati di singer sia vivi che morti si
trovano ovunque tranne che per ora nel
mondo microscopico non siamo riusciti
ancora a mettere così tanti insieme da
generare un computer molto più potente
di quelli attuali questo è per esempio
un elettrone un elettrone nel mondo
quantistico volteggia si chiama spin va
a sinistra oa destra
questo si chiama spin io non riesco a
farlo ma un elettrone può girare a
destra e sinistra simultaneamente
perfetto è stato creato un primo
computer quantistico si più di uno vi
faccio vedere l'ultimo è quello più
famoso si chiama si camorra della google
ed è un computer che per la prima volta
realizzato la supremazia quantistica una
parola che descrive il momento nel quale
un computer quantistico riesce a fare
qualcosa molto ma molto più veloce del
più potente computer attuale sycamore
riuscito a fare un'operazione in un
minuto che avrebbe richiesto ad un
computer al più potente computer attuali
10 milani ma se qualcuno che c'è in
tasca un computer quantistico no allora
che fino a dove sono questi computer
quantistici c'è questo bellissimo
articolo che c'è questo titolo
inquietante computer quantistici ci sono
sono adesso ma non ci sono adesso napt
not now una sovrapposizione di parole ci
sono dei problemi per realizzare un
computer quantistico molto molto potente
che contiene un numero di unità
quantistiche che si chiamano chiude
quindi non più il bit ma il qb bisogna
lasciare il sistema bisogna dare la
possibilità al sistema di rimanere in
questo stato di sovrapposizione si
chiama coerenza è uno stato fragile che
viene disturbato da qualunque particella
che passa vicino al mio computer
quantistico tipo una molecola d'aria
tipo qualunque disturbo elettronico
quindi bisogna isolarlo molto bene ma
non basta bisogna anche essere sicuri
che la meccanica quantistica tutto
sommato è davvero la teoria che funziona
per qualunque sistema indipendente dalle
sue misure piccolo grande la meccanica
quantistica dovrebbe valere ed è quello
che stiamo facendo noi stiamo
interrogandoci sulla natura stessa della
meccanica quantistica di questa teoria
così bizzara che ammette dei jon di gati
la meccanica quantistica vale davvero
per qualunque sistema e lo stiamo
facendo nei laboratori del gran sasso
nel sotterraneo ci siamo chiusi in
questo bellissimo laboratorio sotto le
montagne del gran sasso in una delle
gallerie di questo bellissimo
laboratorio che studia misteri
dell'universo e stiamo indagando su
eventuali punti di rottura della
meccanica quantistica
finora non abbiamo trovato quindi siamo
tranquilli il computer quantistico per
ora regge può essere fatto con un numero
molto grande eddy cue di là dove
riusciamo a salvarci dell'ade coerenza
ma cosa serve cosa possiamo fare quel
che non possiamo fare oggi con un
computer quantistico
beh inutile dirlo che possiamo fare
delle simulazioni realtà virtuali quindi
tutta una serie di conti e di
dissimulazioni più oggi non siamo in
grado di fare e questo potrebbe fungere
da allenamento
per quei quei ambienti in cui non
possiamo farlo in maniera diretta ma
mandiamo qualcuno sulla luna o su marte
lo alleniamo in un ambiente virtuale ma
non solo quello anche per la medicina
oggi prendiamo tutti le stesse medicine
mal di testa
l'aspirina oh beh finché c'è un mal di
testa va bene ma se abbiamo una malattia
più complessa non va bene che prendiamo
le stesse medicine parte degli studi che
bisogna fare necessitano una potenza di
calcolo per capire le proteine i
meccanismi di biologia che oggi non è
disponibile
quindi un computer quantistico potrebbe
aiutarci a personalizzare la cura e la
medicina ma anche a combattere il cyber
terrorismo che sarà la minaccia del
futuro non più i fucili o altro bensì la
minaccia ben più subdola del cyber
terrorismo e questo è un discorso a
parte è finalmente serve anche a capire
meglio il cervello simulazioni del
cervello non solo per capire come
funziona questo meraviglioso organo ma
anche per combattere demenza e
schizofrenia malati e del nostro secolo
e concludo con questa bellissima frase
del padre della meccanica quantistica e
anche del padre dei computer quantistici
reach al fai mar
permettetemi di leggermela che cos'è la
scienza con questa parola
di solito si intendono tre cose diverse
un misto delle tre scienza a volte
significa un metodo speciale di scoprire
le cose a volte l'insieme delle
conoscenze che si originano dalle cose
scoperte ma può anche significare tutte
le cose nuove che si possono fare usando
la conoscenza acquisita ed è proprio
quello di cui vi ho parlato stasera
grazie